et notre premier invité politique ce
matin c'est fini pour tous bonjour merci
bonjour être avec nos philippe poutou
candidat à la présidentielle pour le npa
le nouveau parti anticapitaliste on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
jefferson des sports de sud ouest que
vous connaissez bien c'est votre journal
local fini plus tôt aujourd'hui faire ça
bonjour oriane pour philippe poutou
bonjour on va évidemment longuement
parlé de votre campagne de votre
programme philippe poutou mais d'abord
un mot sur ce qui se passe en ukraine
vous avez vu ces images dans le journal
des dizaines de corps de civils qui ont
été retrouvés à bout de chats dans la
région de kiev après le retrait des
troupes russes et occidentaux dénoncent
des atrocités certains parlent de crime
de guerre est ce que les russes doivent
rendre des comptes pour vous
oui c'est bizarre la question mais on
pense qu'il faut se battre quand la
guerre évidemment néant solidaire de la
population est chrétienne pourquoi ce
visa est ce qu a dit mir poutine doit
rendre des comptes sur ce qui s'est
passé est ce que vous n'avez oui mais
enfin bon je sais pas il ya des
définitions mais en tout cas c'est une
bière puis voilà ça tue des gens ça fait
fuir des gens enfin on voit bien puis
même ya une logique de terreur qui se
met en place parce qu'il s'enlise on
peut dire que c'est positif à portimao
beauty n'arrive pas à gagner mais il
n'arrive pas à gagner mais en même temps
ça pour l'ange est les bombardements et
les tueries et puis on voit que c'est
même un des images qui sont terribles
donc évident mais en fait j'avais dire
comme toutes les guerres quoi et
arrivons à rendre des comptes après mais
on espère bien qu'ils auraient abandonné
une mobilisation à la fois une capacité
de résistance du côté de la population
ukrainienne pin solidarité
internationale en nous quand on parle de
solidarité nationale c'est on espère que
ça va mobiliser les populations qu on
aimerait bien qu'ils aient des
manifestations enfin quelque chose qui
se passe qui permettent aujourd'hui de
faire reculer poutine
son populaire puisque sur l'attitude des
autres impérialisme parce qu'on voit
bien que du côté de l'otan ou du côté de
bail donne l'angleterre ou la france on
sait ce qu'ils sont capables de faire
aussi à l'égard des populations ou des
peuples en ce sens les a vus faire des
interventions militaires de part et
d'autre et puis ai jamais régler ces
questions là on a vu
on a vu la guerre non mais je
comparerais du tout mes 20 ans
d'intervention militaire en afghanistan
pour laisser les talibans prendre le
pouvoir et puis aujourd'hui laisser le
peuple afghan se faire enfermer ou les
femmes afghanes se faire enfermer on a
vu aussi bachar al-assad de massacrer
son peuple c'est pas tout à fait fini
puis aujourd'hui il ya la population
je n'en peux plus metz j'ai un trou là
l'arabie saoudite qui balayé minutes
voilà avec des armées françaises voyez
il ya plein de chose de pourri qui se
passe dans ce monde-là donc nous ce camp
ce conte il ya une urgence aujourd'hui
c'est la solidarité envers la population
ukrainienne donc c'est vrai que nous on
pense que il faut apporter dès la 10è de
logistique par des réseaux militants en
tout cas ça se passe aussi avec des
réseaux syndicalistes ou des réseaux
d'organisations mal à nouer des liens 6
6 6 1 6 6 2 face à une guerre comme ça
face à une ce qu'on appelle la deuxième
armée du monde mais la population
chrétienne a besoin de se défendre
militairement donc si si on est pour le
principe de livraison après le problème
qu'on a c'est que en fait c'est qui qui
va livrer des armes c'est l'otan et est
bon et nous on fait pas du tout alors on
fait pas du tout confiance à l'otan donc
céder c'est aussi une pomme d'une
certaine manière on a connu on est un
peu dans une impuissance là pour ça
qu'on parle beaucoup de mobilisations
populaires parce qu'on pense que l'issue
elle peut être parce que c'est laglais
la lutte contre la guerre contre poutine
fragilisé poutine et faire en sorte
qu'ils se retirent de l'ukraine mais
après c'est aussi la lutte puis générale
contre les dictatures contre ce monde
archi militarisée parce qu'on voit aussi
le danger 1 la garde l'ukraine ce
qu'elle provoque vous avez vu mais
macron diffa va faire augmenter le
budget militaire l'allemagne parlent de
d'euros quand sur une armée on est quand
même dans une logique très dangereuses
ou finalement ben ça peut provoquer des
choses d'autres guère d'autres conflits
en tout cas il ya une bataille contre ce
monde impérialiste capitaliste
revenir à la présidentielle philippe
poutou on est ainsi jour ce matin du 1er
tour pourquoi voter pour vous la
question est très simple parce que vous
ne reconnaissez pas la fonction
présidentielle vous dit que c'est parce
que je ne la reconnaissais pas donc sept
candidats pour une fonction qui nous
aime et c'est passé comme un championnat
de football ya ceux qui jouent le titre
et à ceux qui jouent à autre chose quoi
et
ben justement la critique du système
faire entendre des idées qu'on n'entend
jamais si vous avez remarqué que s'ils
avaient pas les élections
présidentielles on serait jamais
médiatisé même s'ils doivent d'ailleurs
ne s'embête pas ne plus jamais parler du
npa ou quasiment jamais
willan en laissant la présidentielle sur
la présidentielle on va pas régler les
comptes maintenant enfin si ya pas la
présidentielle et quand y'a pas
d'obligation quinté a pas de loi qui
oblige et qui oblige on parle pas de
nous donc la présidentielle s'est déjà
hyper important d'être là pas justement
pour faire entendre la critique du
système capitaliste pas juste pour pour
gueuler contre les injustices et tout ça
parce que c'est vrai que notre programme
c'est une dénonciation des injustices et
puis d'essayer de voir comment il peut y
avoir des réponses politiques avec la
répartition des richesses avec
l'expropriation et puis même des
perspectives politiques d'ouverture des
frontières de liberté de circulation en
fait c'est tout ça qu'on défend mais
c'est aussi de mettre en place afin de
faire exister une perspective politique
qui à l'opposé de la résignation
d'arkoon ce qu'on a envie de faire
passer en cette campagne là c'est que
y'en a marre de subir il faut trouver
les moyens de se défendre de riposter un
peu comme ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en
corse il ya de la colère qui s'exprime
c'est comment on peut la construire
cette colère là et donc c'est un peu ces
choses qu'on voudrait rendre crédible
qui on voudrait discuter et puis par
rapport à ce que vous dites on n'est pas
hors sujet en fait parce que on est dans
la présentielle certes on veut pas de la
fonction présidentielle mais on a quand
même le droit de penser que c'est
profondément antidémocratique c'est ce
qu'on dit hein c'est pas on veut pas du
pouvoir personnel en moi je cherche pas
ça le npa ne cherche pas ça mais par
contre c'est intéressant discuter de ce
que c'est que le pouvoir est ce que ça
pourrait être autre chose qu'un pouvoir
plus collectif un pouvoir des opprimés
pouvoir se
passer de la théorie à la pratique et
c'est compliqué aussi
c'est pas compliqué parce qu'en fait on
nous on critique des institutions pour
nous et décisions elles sont pas du tout
démocratique les institutions et pida et
on le voit bien on est dans un monde qui
est dominé par des ultra riches par les
possédants ils n'ont pas grand-chose à
faire des droits de la population du
droit de logements du droit à l'emploi
tout ça c'est écrasé et donc on remet en
cause ce système là et l'élection ça
permet discuter de ça ça permet de dire
en fait on se fout un peu de nous quand
même élection présidentielle va changer
quoi derrière on a l'expérience quand
même depuis très longtemps et nous on
essaie de discuter qu'est ce qui fait
que ça pourrait changer vraiment pour
les gens et c'est là où ça pose le
problème du pouvoir et celle là ça pose
le problème de la démocratie et l'on
pense qu'aujourd'hui la population
devrait avoir des droits devra avoir du
bois de décider parce que dans votre
profession de foi vous dit c'est pas
l'élection que c'est assez original et
ne s'est pas l'élection qui va changer
les choses il faut imposer le changement
par une mobilisation d'ensemble
concrètement comment vous l'avez m
justement on sait tous que les élections
ça changerait même vous vous savez vous
savez que quel que soit le pouvoir le
chômage augmente la précarité augmente
ça licencie toujours pareil ford à
bordeaux lusine ferme elle est rasé bah
c'est comme ça ça pose plus de problème
on passe à autre chose donc on voit bien
que les élections de toute façon ne
change pas la vie et même au comptant
les élections toujours la situation
concrètement dans 40 ans on a à peu près
les mêmes politiques les mêmes solutions
les
est en fête et même si on a un regard un
peu plus lointain on s'aperçoit bien que
ce qui change vraiment les choses ou ce
qui permet un moment donné de faire
progresser la société ce sont des
mouvements populaires ce sont des luttes
sociales des grèves générales on voit
avec mai 68 avait et tous les mouvements
sociaux qui ont permis des fois où de
ralentir ou d'empêcher des reculs
sociaux ou des fois même de dagany
détruits donc c'est ça qu'on essaie de
discuter c'est qu'en fait la seule façon
de changer les choses c'est qu'il ya un
rapport de force qui soit différent en
fait c'est le problème de comment une
population se défend au quotidien
comment elle défend ses emplois ces
conditions de vie comme on défend nos
services publics au mans défend la santé
un accès au transport l'accès à la
culture et c'est tout le temps des
résistants ça ne peut pas être autre
chose parce qu'en fait le moteur de
l'économie c'est le profit immédiat et
le profit immédiat sera due par quoi
aujourd'hui ben par flinguer tous les
accords va tous les tous les tous les
acquis sociaux et puis ça se traduit par
un enrichissement complètement indécent
des milliardaires on est dans un monde
où nous quand on dit fonds et smic à
1800 euros on nous dit ouais mais
comment vous faites sauf qu'à côté de ça
il ya des milliardaires qui ont comme
arnaud 157 milliards et puis enfin il
suffit de voir le classement des 500
premières fortunes de france on se dit
mais c'est complètement dingue
tout vous financé avec l'argent des
milliardaires si ce que vous dites c'est
à peu près ça a des news qu est ce qu on
dit c'est que les milliardaires c'est de
l'argent volé c'est de l'argent volé
activités on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
être milliardaire normalement ça c'est
pas possible quand on voit le niveau des
salaires des gens qui galèrent 1 comme
les aide soignante à l'hôpital enfin il
ya des tas de boulot très dur très
difficile où c'est du 1200 1300 et 1400
euros et à côté ça on voit des gens
parce qu'ils sont actionnaires ou parce
qu'ils possèdent mais ce sont des
millionnaires des goûts des
milliardaires 11e' un truc qui va
vraiment pas et c'est discuter de ce
système là de cette économie là et
l'élection présentielle doit pouvoir
permettre de discuter de ça dans quelle
société en vie dans quel monde on vit et
est-ce qu'on voit pas est ce qu'il n'ya
pas de problème et une fois qu'on a
constaté un problème comment on peut le
résoudre et c'est ça qu'on essaie de
faire nôtres g c'est la critique et
l'analyse de la situation et de dire ben
oui pour répondre aux urgences sociales
ou environnementales et même
démocratique et b nous on pense qu'il
faut faire comme ça et que la seule
force qui est capable de changer la
donne véritablement c'est une population
qui se défendre est elle-même contre
contre les appétits égoïste de la classe
qui domine alors sur le pouvoir d'achat
parce que c'est la préoccupation
principale en des français philippe
poutou vous le savez vous le dites smic
à 1800 euros nets en déclarations de
revenus sur les prix semaine de 32
heures sur 4 jours en allant vers les 28
heures alors je sais que vous aiderez
c'est principalement aux salariés mais
qu'est ce qu'on vous dit ce matin aux
patrons de tpe pme comment ils mettent
en oeuvre votre votre programme sans
être en difficulté finalement mais après
lens havas à l'ensemble de la population
et y compris ce qu'on pourrait appeler
les petits commerçants les petits
artisans parce que ces gens ces gens là
justement je réponds à votre question
ces gens là sont aussi victimes des
logiques du capitalisme parce que les
gros beauf les petits c'est comme ça
c'est pas c'est pas nous qui avons
inventé la phrase c'est une réalité les
petits commerçants souffrent des gros
chêne de commerce et les petits paysans
souffrent de l'ago l'agro industrie tout
le monde souffre de ce système là en
fait donc après le problème c'est la
remise en cause de ces 207 course au
profit et la remise en cause du pouvoir
ou du sur pouvoir des puissants et des
gros possédants et donc on discute
effectivement pour nous à la base déjà
et c'est quand même temps que ça puisse
être surprenant c'est qu'on discute de
comment une société peut assurer des
moyens de subsistance minimum à toute la
population c'est ça qu'on discute et si
le système économique il n'est pas
capable d'assurer l'emploi il n'est pas
capable de protéger les gens c'est un
système qu'il faut renverser parce que
c'est ça qui on est dans une société on
vit ensemble on doit avoir un système
qui permet de garantir d'abord l'emploi
ou un revenu minimum pour tout le monde
c'est vrai que nous on est pour 1800 run
est pourquoi 1800 rhône est pas un c'est
un revenu pour tout le monde les
retraités l'allocation adulte handicapé
les indemnités chômage on veut quand on
pense que les gens doivent pouvoir avoir
une assurance de ce côté là et a suscité
doit pouvoir le garantir avant les
profits avant que et c'est ça qu'il faut
inverser en fait et avec les petites
entreprises avec abc ça qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à mettre en place une économie
qui permet justement à tout le monde de
fonctionner comme ça et une petite
entreprise qui est pas capable d'assurer
des salaires normaux
à des salariés c'est un problème donc
oui il faut créer un autre système et
nous on discute d'une sécurité sociale
généralisée même le système bancaire un
stand car il doit être expropriés
socialiser de manière à ce qu'il joue
son rôle d' aide à tout le monde et pas
de remplir les poches des milliardaires
et pas de permettre l'évasion fiscale
n'est pas de permettre la triche comme
on le voit avec eux d'ailleurs le
pouvoir en place ça triche à fond avec
leurs amis les riches mckinsey tous ah
bon nous on veut un système de contrôle
public va évidemment mais pour tout le
monde et de la triche même vous vous
pensez que de la tristesse
asfc faut pas faire l'erreur mais entre
nous lie à personnes qui nous écoutent
au buzz parfait
évidemment qu'elle la triche à tous les
niveaux et c'est ce système lac qui
amendait il faut quand même discuté
concrètement et sérieusement que ben il
faut changer ça oui il faut changer ça
vous voulez socialiser les banques vous
les exproprier les grandes entreprises
vous faites quoi s'énerve ou socialisé
tout métier tout sous le sceau de l'état
mais nous on pense que c'est les
secteurs vitaux de l'économie en fait
d'abord après on verra mais c'est vrai
que la santé l'énergie le logement
c'est comment on peut faire des services
qui soient fin des services publics mais
que ce soit un outil public sous
contrôle de la population il faut
trouver des formes c'est là aussi il ya
une démocratie directe à construire mais
c'est pas tellement l'idée de
l'étatisation de la nationalisation
parce qu'on a bien vu que ça peut ne pas
fonctionner du tout aussi mais c'est
comment on met en place des des outils
économiques qui soient vraiment sous
contrôle public il permet justement de
de mettre en place des politiques qui
répondent aux urgences sociales ou
environnementales ou encore une fois
démocratique et c'est c'est pour ça que
nous on pense qu'il faut exproprier bon
les banques que ce que j'ai dit mais
même l'industrie pharmaceutique par
exemple c'est un scandale de voir
comment les profits qui sont faits là
dessus à partir de l'épidémie de la
pandémie et puis deux à côté ça qui a
pas de moyens pour les hôpitaux
canadiens on nous dit qu'il n'a pas
d'argent pour embaucher et renforcer les
personnels soignants et enfin il ya un
truc qui va pas du tout quoi et donc
c'est vrai que c'est arrivé à exproprier
à socialiser comme ça en capte les
profits et les profits au lieu d'être
maintenue entre les mains d'une poignée
qui puisse être redistribuées et sert et
être utile à la société sade et rui
renforcer sa suite donc ce sont des
secteurs vitaux qu'il faut socialiser
immédiatement sur le nucléaire vous dit
arrête du nucléaire et des énergies
fossiles en disant ça veut dire que pour
vous en 2032 il faut plus qu' aucune
centrale nucléaire en activité dans le
pays belle plus vite possible ça après
c'est difficile de fixer une date exacte
mais c'est vrai qu'en tout cas ya des
mais des mouvements écologistes qui
disent qu en disant à rien a qui disent
tous les ans c'est parce que regarder ce
matin par exemple à l'heure actuelle il
ya 27 centrales
règne dans le pays sur les sur les 58 et
rte demande déjà d'eau français de
restreindre leurs consommations
d'électricité savons pas répondre à ça
tombe déjà sont pas capables de gérer le
système actuel de manière comment dire
cohérente mais non mais la question à l
inverse est ce que ça vous paraît
possible d'accumuler les déchets
nucléaires pendant encore des décennies
alors quand on sait que personne ne sait
quoi en faire et que ça va nous péter à
la gueule demain est ce que ça nous
paraît possible de vivre les directeurs
comme plus de 40 ans avec les risques a
augmenté de d'accident nucléaire nous on
pense que c'est trop dangereux pour
prendre ce risque là donc on discute
effectivement et ça nous parle et
rationnelle ça nous paraît cohérent ben
oui sortons du nucléaire le plus vite
possible sortons des énergies fossiles
évidemment avec les gaz à effet de serre
ça nous paraît pas aussi celle inverse
qui paraît pas possible après ici à
l'essai des choix politiques pourquoi ce
serait pas possible c'est comme
aujourd'hui à 2 les milliardaires font
des milliards c'est possible et puis ya
de la misère c'est possible tout est
possible
c'est la question et bien c'est la
question de choix politique à faire et
on paie aujourd'hui il veut et où les
scientifiques il suffit de lire les
rapports du giec et le rapport du giec
sont pas des gauchistes il ya des tas de
possibilités aujourd'hui c'est une
question de choix politique comment on
décide ces choses là et ce qui nous
manque c'est ça c'est des cdd des
directions politiques qui
je continue à parler comme des
directions politiques afin d'aider des
chefs d état qui sont pas dans la
capacité de changer de politique parce
qu'ils sont trop au service des logiques
capitalistes conso profite donc
évidemment à la pétrochimie litres de
carburant ça rapporte tellement de
pognon qu'on continue comme ça le
nucléaire c'est quand même des affaires
énorme pour certains et c'est ça qui
fait qu'on peut pas en sortir c'est tous
ces mensonges là en disant on peut pas
en sortir parce que et puis c'est comme
l'agriculture productiviste on nous dit
on peut pas faire autrement faut
utiliser les pesticides et fongicides et
tout ça mais en réalité c'est parce
qu'on est dans des logiques de
rentabilité s'ils ont rampé avec c'est
logique là on verrait cas la possibilité
de faire une agriculture beaucoup plus
humaine est beaucoup plus de proximité
et en se sortant justement de tous ces
éléments chimiques et enfin en
renforçant la petite paysannerie et pour
l'énergie c'est pareil
là il faudrait un service public de
l'énergie avec encore une fois à
l'expropriation de total est
un outil qui soit vraiment entre les
mains de public andy on verra comment on
fait comment on fait pour la fois
répondre à la question de l'urgence
climatique et en même temps du danger
pour l'humanité et s'ils avaient un
pouvoir qui était quand même raisonnée
et raisonnable et qui avait comme
préoccupation ces choses là ça se
passerait différemment donc c'est
vraiment une question de choix politique
et de et de mettre tout le monde un peu
dans la capacité de pouvoir décider ces
choses-là sur l'énergie philippe poutou
face à la flambée des prix des
carburants vous faites quoi il ya des
remises sur le prix du litre d'essence
fait par le gouvernent et ça c'est nous
on pense que le minimum c'est le blocage
est pris c'est ce qu'on dit à son c'est
la question d'accès logo note là on n'en
sait rien on n'est pas là mais mais tout
est beaucoup trop chères banques c'est à
la fois le blocage est pris et même
certainement la baisse des prix et puis
le salaire minimum dès maintenant en
urgence il faudrait faire mais ce qu'on
dit 1800 euros qui permettrait aux gens
de vivre beaucoup mieux et de faire face
à l'augmentation des prix si jamais elle
est très difficile à maîtriser mais oui
ce sont toutes ces choses là mais nous
on pense que la politique de l'énergie
et les conséquences s'il y avait un tel
service public et si on expropriés
justement tous ces profiteurs on verrait
bien que l'argent déjà il partirait un
pas forcément vers le haut mais qui
seraient redistribuées et c'est vraiment
le problème politique qu'on a c'est
cette redistribution des richesses
immédiate un mot sur la corse et
manifestation hier en hommage à yvan
colonna avec de nouvelles violences 15
blessés vous êtes pour l'autonomie de la
corse est ce qu a quand même des lignes
rouges pour vous nos bas la ligne rouge
allait déjà franchi par le gouvernement
depuis très longtemps parce qu'à force
de se fout de la gueule des
nationalistes corses ça provoque ça
parce qu'en fait ils ont baratiner ils
ont baladé les corses parents très
longtemps et macron il a très bien joué
fait ce jeu-là darmana macron et la
salle en retournant sur parce qu'en fait
ces braves et celle déclenchée par la
mort de colonnes et aujourd'hui ça a
déclenché une colère des jeunes dans la
rue et puis oui il ya un peuple corse il
ya une histoire il ya des droits et ces
droits sont pas reconnus donc en fait la
ligne rouge c'est ça c'est pas c'est pas
les corses qui l'a francis s'est
complètement légitime de dire bah oui
mais nous on veut enlever ou de respect
de nos droits notre culture notre langue
nous ce qu'on dit c'est qu'en fait une
démocratie si vraiment la république
française c'était une démocratie ça ne
l'est pas mais on imagine à l'it elle
est démocratique elle respecte les
peuples eh bien elle donne le droit à
l'autonomie de ces peuples là elle
permet développer de référendum des
discussions et est parti il ya des
pommes mais bien aussi le peuple basque
il ya en bretagne et puis la guyane où
la nouvelle calédonie qui s'est fait
avoir par macro encore une fois avec un
référendum qui est qui a qui repousse
pour combien de temps on sait pas l'idée
de l'indépendance mais c'est quand même
le minimum de des peuples revendiquent
des droits ils demandent le droit de
s'organiser par eux mêmes mais il faut
le donner à avoir lieu dans le contexte
actuel avec ces violences on vous dit il
faut d'abord
justement c'est parce qu'il a ça que la
discussion est possible et tant qu'ils
avaient pas la colère tant qu'à pas les
manifs et pis c'est pour ça que s'il
faut brûler une sous préfecture et b&b
c'est comme ça que ça marche que vous
encourager ces violences on encourage un
puisque ça a lieu sans nous ce que nous
on constate c'est que si elle est pas ça
darmanin et flea prépa il parlait pas
d'autonomie ci avait pas ça il aurait
pas
c'est une réponse philippe poutou les
faits la violence est la violence enfin
la colère est légitime et la violence
légitime la partie moment il ya une
violence de l'oppression déjà l'état
français il est bien parce qu'en fait il
faudra quand même rappeler que le début
des violences dans les manifs y compris
en corse ben cesser les attaques des crs
parce qu'il ya quand même des tirs de l
bd ya eu des blessés graves on n'en
parle pas beaucoup mais y'a des
manifestants compris des tirs dans la
tête dans le torse encore ça et puis les
combats que dont on parle aujourd'hui
d'un cd réponse à l'agression policière
aux agressions de la répression
politique donc c'est vrai c'est ça aussi
c'est qu'en fait souvent la colère passe
en fait des populations elles sont hyper
sympa sauf qu'à m'en donner ça passe
plus attendre a forcé faute fout de la
gueule du monde et d'écraser les gens
parce que la corse est pas juste une
question de déni démocratique c'est
aussi de la pauvreté ceci la difficulté
pour la jeunesse de se loger c'est la
spéculation immobilière c'est la
bétonisation décote en fait ce qu'on
appelle le tourisme et bien en fait ça
profite à une poignée et puis la
population elle en souffre donc tout ça
ça s'accumule et abandonné ça pète et
quand ça pète c'est sympa ce que parce
que c'est normal que la pôle country ça
va jusqu'à des formes de violence
belfort de glace encore une fois c'est
d'abord la violence d'état et après il
faut se défendre mais quand c'est la
question de la légitime défense quand on
est attaqué quand il ya du chômage de la
précarité qu'on nous écoute pas
que notre histoire n est pas reconnue
mais que si vous voulez sont cités sont
en baisse la tête et derrière c'est vrai
que c'est ça le pouvoir si ce que veut
le pouvoir s'est écrasé les gens c'est
les faire taire le mouvement des gis
légende c'était ça c'est taisez vous
restez chez vous ici vous êtes encore
dans la rue on vous tire dessus c'est ça
et alors à partir de ce moment là
comment on fait comment on change les
choses comment se défend et et la
démocratie doit reconnaître le droit de
contester le droit de se battre bah oui
c'est comme ça et là et la violence et b
dans l'histoire tu as sont belles et des
fois le résultat aussi de du sur
violence du pouvoir et à un moment donné
les opprimés se révoltent se bat et
c'est et voilà et c'est comme ça et nous
ça nous gêne pas et nous on est plutôt
rassuré quand on voit la population
réagir en tout cas nous on est solidaire
de la colère aujourd'hui du peuple corse
sinon il nous reste quatre minutes
philippe poutou avant sur semble sans
doute entendu emmanuel macron samedi
désir cette phrase durant son meeting
leurs vies valent plus que tous les
profits c'est ce qu'il a dit à propos
des aînés qui sont dans les ehpad
paragraphe slogan comment vous avez
réagi à ça ben enfin tard à face comment
on réagit c'est vrai que c'est
surprenant se dit quel culot quel culot
après si on se dit que si on avait su on
aurait breveté le truc comme ça ne
rigole plus d'argent puisque en fait aux
digues certains arrières on est devenu
un cabinet conseil et voilà mais bon
après on est tellement généreux comment
on va là gratuit prenez prenez
voilà ces cadeaux mais bon derrière
c'est surtout le cynisme de ces gens là
c'est qu'en fait ils ont tout ça bah
ouais c'est fini parce que la pratique
de macron c'est la pratique inverse
c'est à dire ça a été de soutenir ses
amis les riches ça a été de soutenir
tous les actionnaires et tous appuyé de
laisser faire parce que en fait la
question d'aider des ehpad on le sait
depuis très longtemps il y avait des
mots mobilisation du personnel les ehpad
ya quelques années pour dénoncer
justement à la fois la maltraitance des
groupes privés même si dans le public
c'est pas toujours nickel monf en tout
cas dans les groupes privés y avait une
grosse maltraitance et puis une
maltraitance pas que des personnes en
situation de dépendance mais aussi des
salariés qui étaient amenés à être
maltraitant envers envers les anciens
parce que ils n'avaient pas les moyens
donc en fait il ya c'est pour ça qu'à
l'urgence de service unique là encore un
pour le quatrième âge pour pour les
ehpad et puis là là on a l'exemple
concret comment enlever les moyens de
nuire aux capitalistes et aux groupes
privés et bcc expropriés et c'est rendre
publique cette gestion l'abbé macron et
sa bande ils ont géré les choses comme
ça et puis maintenant ils peuvent faire
un peu mais c'est vrai quand même la
course aux profits c'est dégueulasse et
puis en reprenant des slogans du npa ou
de la sr bon voilà c'est cynique et ça
montre que
on espère que derrière ça met en
évidence l'urgence qu'il ya de
reconstruire des services publics
aujourd'hui chez les ouvriers dans les
classes populaires mis au vote marine le
pen comment vous l'expliquez est ce que
je demande c'est elle qui répond
aujourd'hui à la colère sociale plus que
non elle répond pas mais de fait c'est
vrai que après on n'explique pas tout
parce que ça nous dépasse ou 6 à ce
point là parce que c'est le pen et c'est
zemmour si on fait épique dupont aignan
parler pour parler de l'extrême droite
c'est énorme c'est plus de 30% en fait
dans les sondages en tout cas et puis et
puis à côté ça on voit une pécresse
hyper extrême droite enfin c'est
droites extrêmes après la différence des
fois ciotti compagnie fin va lasser ou
la frontière en lamé ou quoi puis même
après avec macron quand on voit ce
qu'ils font ce qu'ils pratiquent la
répression la chasse aux migrants tout
ça on se dit en fait on est dans un
monde qui est largement dominé par les
idées réactionnaires et puis même
quelque part des idées fascisantes on
est en danger de ce point de vue là donc
après c'est vrai que ce qui nous fait
peur aussi est ce qu'on a du mal à
comprendre c'est mais on peut un petit
peu le comprendre c'est comment des
partis comme le fait elle arrive à
récupérer ou à détourner le
mécontentement social et puis ça et leur
idéal ils ont donné ccq socialisme
c'est l'échec de bonnes choses en fait
c'est l'échec de pentium et c'est aussi
un système qui est tellement oppressif
tellement destructeur qui broie et c'est
pas vous qui travaillez pas vous qui
trouvent ils pas les réponses mais bon
on peut dire ça a bien sûr parce qu'on
voit bien notre propre impuissance et
c'est pour ça qu'on est là aussi dans
une campagne électorale c'est d'essayer
de formule des choses parce qu'on met
tout le monde est un peu responsable ce
même les médias d'une certaine manière
ils ont leur propre responsabilité parce
que quand on voit l'espace occupé par
l'extrême droite dans les médias comparé
à l'espace occupé par nous on se dit
quand même un déséquilibre qui dont on
qui se paye un moment donné donc c'est
pas toujours facile expliqué mais on
voit bien qu'il ya il ya un vrai souci
c'est qu'en fait c'est paradoxal la
souffrance sociale des fois elles
s'expriment derrière des candidatures
qui sont à la fois du camp des riches du
candy système et qui en plus sont des
ont des idées dangereuses puisque en
fait c'est la mise en place d'une
société hyper autoritaire et c'est ce
qu'on appelle aussi le fascisme en bout
de course dont on pense qu'il ya un
danger et comment on convint comment on
discute bon voilà c'est aussi l'époux
toucy dimanche et un deuxième tour qui a
posé manuel à croire marine le pen vous
prononcerez clairement en 17 on avait
dit qu'on voterait pas donc on peut
penser que sous la
la la on à la difficulté en plus un
maquereau qui nous a flingué qu'à
attaquer qui a une politique
ultralibérale épique à réprimer comme un
dingue donc c'est évident que c'est un
autre problème mais nous on pense que
l'extrême droite pensent que
l'extrême-droite et l'autoritarisme ça
se combat dans la rue avant tout et
c'est pour ça que notre préoccupation
c'est le mouvement social etc même y
compris de reconstruire une gauche et de
reconstruire une gauche mais cette fois
radicale anticapitaliste et c'est un peu
ça qu'on fera des dès la fin du premier
tour c'est de s'adresser un peu tout le
monde largement comment on fait pour se
défendre parce qu'une fois que
l'élection est passée on va se retrouver
avec les mêmes merde le chômage la
précarité la destruction des services
publics des politiques ultralibérales en
perspective des attaques sur la retraite
et compagnie donc il va falloir qu'on
lance un appel large à l'ensemble des
forces de gauche y compris à celles et
ceux qui ont voté pour différentes
candidatures à gauche comment se
mobilisent comment on prépare la riposte
il ya un enjeu politique pour nous qui
sera celui-là et dernière question
rapidement sur born oui parce que
philippe poutou faisait franchi le cap
de l'élection ce qui est pas évident au
npa vous êtes conseiller municipal à
bordeaux vous êtes un groupe de trois et
ce groupe s'est scindé en deux voué une
autre élue contre une autre élue c'est
difficile de passer de la théorie à la
pratique vous aussi vous êtes rattrapé
par finalement les divisions ouais mais
il ya toujours des divisions mais c'est
comme ça ça fait partie de la vie et on
dédramatise parce qu'en fait on continue
à faire notre boulot ça ne change rien
il ya deux groupes aujourd'hui deux
équipes militantes qui se sont disputés
on verra si la suite fait qu'on se
retrouve ou pas
non non pas du tout pour l'instant on
n'a aucune nouvelle s'était dit mais on
n'a rien et en fait nous ça change rien
dans le sens où on continue à faire
notre boulot d'opposant politiques de
gauche aient envie qu'on défend ce que
nous on pense être une vraie politique
de gauche et services publics et tout ça
voilà b après on a malheureusement
l'histoire militante elle est faite de
sa lé fait partout
l'entente sein du groupe hurmic ce n'est
pas si simple que ça l'entente dans la
droite ils se disputent aussi fait la
vie politique et pas si simple que ça
mais bon après il faut pas lâcher le
morceau de ce qu'on a fait c'était de
faire entendre une voix populaire au
parlement bordeaux n'est on continue de
la même manière possible merci à vous
tous merci beaucoup merci à marc était
notre invité candidat du npa pour cette
élection présidentielle
[Musique]